as many of you know, if you watched yesterday's
program over the weekend, uh, what Bernie
Sanders did in Nevada was when handily and
MSNBC and also CNN absolutely imploded into
centrist establishment, status quo hysteria.
And I consider it my responsibility as an
independent news host who keeps an eye on
corporate media to report that to you, to
report to you the atrocities that are taking
place on corporate media.
And I did that yesterday.
One of the things that took place that was
probably the height of absurdity during MSNBC
coverage was Chris Matthews equating Bernie's
win in Nevada.
Bernie being a Jewish man, no less likening
that victory to the Nazi invasion of France
during world war II.
Now, many other things happened during MSNBC
coverage had included reporters with visible,
clear disdain for Bernie Sanders.
I reported that to you and unfortunately my
video bringing to you this report yesterday
about the atrocious coverage on corporate
media of Bernie's.
When was instantly demonetized by YouTube
for accurately quoting Chris Matthews use
of the word Nazi because that is not suitable
for advertisers.
And what I want people to really understand
is that this is a self perpetuating cycle
of legacy corporate media, uh, insulating
themselves from criticism, having any effect
on what they do in their profitability.
They do laughable embarrassing coverage all
day Saturday.
They're behaving as if there's been a terrorist
attack or children murdered.
But actually what happened is Bernie won when
a primary, uh, and then I cover that for you.
And we lose out on income for the day income
that we use to pay salaries.
And health insurance and connectivity and
bandwidth and studio rent and all of that
stuff.
There is a structural and systemic disincentive
for me to cover the absurdity that is taking
place with an establishment corporate media
every day with every delegate that Bernie
achieves.
The hysteria on corporate media rises to the
point where Chris Matthews is saying, this
is like when Nazis took over France.
He's since sort of apologized for that, uh,
different opinions about the, uh, a sort of
honesty of that apology.
This is self perpetuating.
The centers of power are reinforced by channels
like MSNBC and others.
And then when we an independent media critique
them, we are demonetized, which will serve
to reduce the number of critiques.
And of course, there's the fact that many
of these channels have different deals with
YouTube such that they can talk about a Nazi
invasion of Germany by Germany and they make
money from it.
But if I point out, look at what they're doing,
we lose money for doing it.
So we're up against it this year.
Big time.
Today, we're talking about how to protect
yourself from the historic record levels of
disinformation propaganda that are expected
to plague the primary and the election.
We now also have to fight against the reality
that the more absurd corporate media gets
in their coverage, the more independent media
risks losing our financial stability by covering
their absurdity.
Understand how unsustainable that is as a
status quo.
The crazier they get, the less we make by
exposing it because their statements are not
advertiser safe.
Understand the lunacy of that situation.
So we've got a fund media we support directly.
If it's not this show, if it's, if you like
some other independent host better than me,
peace and love support them.
If you appreciate this program, we're going
to keep covering establishment media no matter
what.
What I'm asking for is your support on this
front.
So consider grabbing a membership@joinpacman.com
we have a massive coupon code.
2020 now saves you 66% I just got into a brawl
outside of the studio with my staff.
They were beating me saying, do not offer
a 66% discount.
And then I beat them.
Somehow.
We're all physically unscathed, but in any
case, it's a huge discount.
2020.
Now we'll save you 66% off of a membership@joinedpacman.com.
Also, feel free to make a pledge on Patrion
at patrion.com/david Pakman show.